welcome to sas talks money where all we
talk is money i'm your host adam sosnick
and i'm here
to help you build your wealth and save
that money on today's episode we
breaking down
all things nba money who's making it who
blew it
and what you can learn from ballin in
the nba
let's talk money all we talk is money
all we talk is money
all we talk is money the nba is
officially back they're playing in the
orlando bubble and i couldn't be more
excited
for nba action it's fantastic if you
don't know about me i'm a huge fan of
the nba
i've been watching it and playing it
since i was a kid i even had a little
game
myself but now i'm in the money game and
i want to give you a little game on how
to build
your wealth so now let's jump right into
the
20 highest paid nba players
in 2020 so right here i have a list of
the 20
highest paid players in the nba this
season
i've even added three names that are on
my
honorable mention list number 42 the mvp
giannis ortega cumpo did i say his name
right
this guy's the mvp he's not even the
highest paid player on his team
he makes 25.8 million number 27
on this list joelle embiid i remember
his rookie year
he'd be in miami a lot we would hang
he'd be sipping on shirley temples
in the club did not drink alcohol did
not play he has now become
the process and probably the best big
man in the nba
number 21 on this list i added him
because i like his nickname he just
barely missed the cut mr dame dollar he
makes 29.8 million dollars
now let's get into the top 20. number 20
number 19 what i'll call the paul
brothers paul millsap paul george each
clearing
30 million dollars a year chris
middleton that's giannis's
teammate he's the highest paid player on
that team he makes
30.6 million moving forward we've got
kyrie irving probably the sickest
handles in the league number 16 mike
conley he's now a point guard
for utah great player for with memphis
now on utah
15 and 14 you got gordon hayward and you
got kemba
walker both playing for the boston
celtics these days number 13
probably the sweetest shot in the nba mr
clay thompson he's injured right now
but he'll be back next season he makes
32.7 million
number 12 you got kawhi leonard the claw
he was the mvp for the toronto raptors
last year they won the world
championship
he's a fun guy if you didn't know number
11 he plays for my
miami heat we're talking about jimmy
butler complete team leader right there
now let's get into the top ten you got
tobias harris somehow
making 32.7 million dollars a year
getting paid like an all-star
even though he's never been an all-star
number nine
the dunk machine himself blake griffin
he's playing for detroit these days
number eight you got kyle lowry he was
the point guard
for the toronto raptors when they won
the championship last year
total pit bull that guy he's making just
under 35 million
number seven you might have heard of
this guy before he goes by lebron james
he's balling for the lakers these days
their odds are probably the favorite to
win
this season i don't know what do you
think the lakers are going to win the
raptors going to win again who's gonna
win i don't know
number six you got the offensive machine
the beard james harden
he makes 38 million number five kevin
durant he plays for book and well
not really playing right now but plays
for brooklyn makes 38 million
number four you got john wall total
all-star when he's playing but hasn't
played in
two years but he's still collecting
checks number two and number three
you got russell westbrook and chris paul
they were actually
traded for each other in the off season
they both make
38.5 million and number one on this list
well i've left that off the list because
i wanted to see if you knew who
that was he's the only player in the nba
making 40
million dollars this season drop a
comment let me know if you
know who it is take a guess we'll be
revealing that at the end
of this segment so we've gone through
the top 20 list plus an honorable
mention now
it's time to get into the 10 reasons
these ballers
go broke now before we go through this
top 10 list let's just
state a couple not so fun facts these
careers
don't last as long as you think in fact
the average
nba career lasts less than five years
and in fact
sixty percent of nba players end up
actually broke
within five years of retirement so to
put it in perspective the average
nfl career lasts less than three years
and 80 percent of nfl players end up
going broke
within two years of retirement so now
the number one reason ballers end up
broke is
because they have no game plan now in
the money world
a budget is a game plan for your money
it's funny to me
these athletes always have game plans on
the field
but off the field no financial game plan
so
what am i trying to say is it is
important to be ballin
on a budget i actually sat down with a
good buddy of mine chris humphries he
played in the nba for 13 years
he talked about cash flow i look at cash
flow
okay how much am i getting in each month
to live off of gotta have some cash flow
what's coming in the door
what's going out the door income versus
expenses
this is very very important whether
you're making
five million dollars a year or whether
you're making 50 000 a year it's
important to have a game plan
for your money now speaking of balling
on a budget i actually sat down with a
good buddy of mine
kelly olynyk and he said the most
important thing that you can
understand is how much does it cost to
be
you know how much it costs to be you
does it cost
1500 a month does it cost 3 000 a month
20 000 a month add it up
know what it costs to be you and make
sure you're living with that
and then once you know what it costs to
be you
look back at it and figure out how can
you make it
cost less to be yourself you know that's
something that i
i did after you know being in the mba
and and seeing like wow i spend you
spend a lot of money and you don't even
realize it
yeah is you know how can you make it
cost
less to to be yourself pretty deep
insights from an nba baller so these are
ballers with game plans but the reason
that ballers end up going broke is
because they have no game plan so
understand that you need a game plan
for your money number two reason uncle
sam
aka the tax man don't forget to pay the
tax man so understand something they say
there are two
certainties in life one is death and
number two is taxes
so whether you're making 30 million
dollars a year or 30 000
a year don't forget to pay your taxes
now if you're a professional athlete you
should understand something
there's something called the jock tax
yes that's a real tax now what is this
this jock tax states this you gotta pay
taxes
in every city and state that you play in
so if you're an nba player
and you have 82 games in a season so
that means you got 41 home
and 41 away that means you need to
understand that you're paying different
taxes in every single different city and
state that you play
so you better have a good cpa to keep
track of all your taxes so that's
something you should understand
now not only are you paying taxes on
your earnings
you might also have endorsements you got
shoe deals you got clothing deals
you got people that pay you for
autographs you also have endorsements
so the reason this is number two for a
couple different reasons you got death
and you got taxes
you got the jock taxes that you're
paying city and state tax in different
cities
but also you got to pay taxes on your
earnings and your endorsements
don't forget to pay the tax man and
number three is the big three i'm not
talking about the boston celtics big
three
or the miami heat big three i'm talking
about the bad
big three the three things that ballers
spend money on
that always loses their money which is
this is cars
clothes and jewelry i'll say it again
cars
clothes and jewelry i sound like a rap
video right now cars clothes money cash
clothes money class coats
i think clothes and jewelry and cars you
know all depreciating assets clothes
usually aren't worth anything
cars depreciated in rapid rate jewelry
typically you know you're getting ripped
off cars
clothes jewelry cars closing jewelry
they are depreciating
assets a couple different case examples
of ballers who have gone
full-on broke here we go case example
number one
derek coleman he played for the new
jersey nets for a long time
he made 87 million dollars over his
career
but he loved handsome rolly rolly rolly
rollies
he loved them so much in fact he now
owes
more than five million dollars to
creditors and he is now bankrupt
for all that spending case example
number two his name will come up
pretty often throughout this post a
child for going broke from the nba
antoine walker made 110 million dollars
over his career but he loved him some
cars
he actually loved cars so much he had
over 10 different cars just
sitting there while he was balling what
kind of cars did he have
well the usual two bentleys two bends a
maybach
a hummer the list goes on and on ten
cars he's now
broke and he actually lectures young
ballers on how
not to end up going broke so what's the
big three
cars clothes and jewelry number four
hiring
the wrong advisor now every nba baller's
got a guy
they got a money guy they got someone
who manages their money but my question
is
who's the guy is he a trustworthy person
is it a guy that someone else knows is
it an uncle's friend
who's the guy so here's my advice to you
ballers out there and to actually
you high earners out there you ready
make sure you're dealing with a
qualified
professional make sure they're
trustworthy and here's a key term for
you
are they a fiduciary a fiduciary looks
out
for your best interest in mind remember
that term
fiduciary now the exact opposite of a
fiduciary is what i would call
a fedoche bag a fa douche bag is someone
who basically looks out
for their interests not yours now who am
i talking about
shady agents maybe some guy who's run a
little ponzi scheme you're not so sure
about
just basically people who are concerned
about their commissions and not yours
so do my ballers out there understand if
you're dealing with a fiduciary
or a douche bag now if you are working
with someone who has your best
interests in mind here's the catch you
ready you ready
you gotta listen to them when they
telling you stop spending your money
you have to listen because you can lead
a horse to water but you can't make them
drink so if you're making this money and
you're hiring a good advisor
and they're telling you not to spend
your money on certain things you need to
listen
the number five reason is the homies you
want to be rolling with the homies
i understand it you came up you want to
bring your friends with you
you want to have an entourage you want
to roll with your crew that's cool
but that doesn't mean you need to pay
for everybody you always hear
ballers make it to the nba the first
thing they want to do they want to buy
their mom a house
that's cool buy your mom a house buy
your mom a million dollar house
but don't buy all your friends houses
and don't buy all your friends cars
and don't give all your friends payments
every single month just to be your
friend now let me break that down even
further with a couple
case examples case example number one
you got big eddie curry this guy made
60 million dollars over his career now
he's flat broke one of the reasons
he was paying friends and family sixteen
thousand dollars a month
just to hang with the dude you need
someone to hang with you that much
number one i'll do it but number two
maybe you get yourself a dog
who doesn't need that much money case
example number two i told you earlier
antoine walker
this guy had 70 family and friends on
the payroll
he blew through 110 million dollars
so here's the key lesson with all these
friends and family on the payroll
one word two letters learn how to say
no you can't support everybody so it's
cool to have the homies it's cool to
have family in your life
but sometimes you need to say no number
six
baby mama drama this is something that
plagues
the playa players out there all right
the goal as you should know is to have
one baby mama we call her a wife maybe
the relationship doesn't work out now
you got
a second wife or a second baby mama but
the goal should be putting up stats on
the scoreboard
not in the baby mama department so let's
unpack a couple case examples
of players who got so many baby mamas
that it's like a triple double
gone wrong case example number one you
got my man
dwight howard this guy is a beast on the
court but apparently he's a beast
off the court as well he's got five kids
from five different women
case example number two you got sean
kemp seven kids
six different women case example number
three you got this guy
jason caffey he played for the bulls for
many seasons
kind of during the mj days he's got 10
kids
with eight different women those aren't
the kind of stats you're looking to put
up
in fact he was recently arrested for
failure to pay child support
and he's now officially bankrupt okay
so when we're talking about baby mama
drama you do not need that in your life
and what is the monetary reason for that
well on average for all you young people
out there starting to have kids
the average cost to raise a kid from
zero to 18
is a quarter million dollars now times
that times two kids
times that times three kids times five
kids times ten kids
jason cafe i understand why you can't
pay child support
so save that money and save that baby
mama drama
number seven flexing now when i think of
flexing i think of trying to keep
up with the joneses now i'm not talking
about derrick jones
or eddie jones or damien joe's or even
popeye jones i'm talking about keeping
up
with the joneses so let me unpack that a
little bit what does it mean to be
keeping up with the joneses
now there's a big difference if you're
playing in the nba also if you're
playing in the real world
there's a big difference between being
the starter
and a max contract than being a bench
warmer and the 12th man on the bench
making a minimum contract there's a big
difference between making 30 million a
year
and 1 million a year even in the nba so
if you're making one million dollars a
year
don't try to keep up with the guy making
30 million dollars a year you're not on
his level
just like if you're making 50 000 a year
and your buddy's making 250 000
a year you're not on his level
financially so stop trying to keep
up with the joneses couple case examples
of trying to keep up with the joneses
you got seven footer david harrison made
four million dollars in the league
he was at one point a mcdonald's
all-american then he went to start
working
at mcdonald's because he blew through
all four million dollars
case example number two you got vin
baker he made a hundred million dollars
he was an all-star
who ended up working at starbucks so
these are the type of situations that
you have
where you're making 30 million dollars a
year or whether you're making a million
dollars a year
stay in your lane and know your role
now speaking of staying in your lane
let's get into number eight which is bad
business investments now when you're a
baller and you're making millions
in the nba everyone's going to come up
to you
with a sick idea and the only catch with
this sick idea
is they need your money now what do
these
sick ideas usually include well it's
usually a record label
a bar or restaurant or a clothing line
those are sort of the deals
that you get approached with now here's
what i'll say about these bad business
ideas
not every great idea is profitable and
not every business
is fun so check this out just because
you like listening to music doesn't mean
you need to own
a record label just because you wear
clothes doesn't mean you need to
run a clothing line and just because you
eat at restaurants and drink at bars
doesn't mean you need to own one so
understand the difference
between a good business investment and
staying in your lane and focusing on
your skill set
versus a bad business investment number
nine
cribs we've all seen the mtv show cribs
welcome to my crib
now who are the most common people on
that show whether it's ballers
it's rappers welcome to the crib come on
in my crib check out the crib check out
the swimming pool
check out the basketball court in the
back check out the man den over here
now here's the problem with cribs you
should just own one
you don't need multiple cribs cribs
aka mortgages a lot of times are
e-liquid assets meaning you can't get
rid of them
when you want to get rid of them case
example michael jordan who's not broke
for that matter
michael jordan was trying to sell his
chicago mansion
for 29 million dollars while that's been
on the market for eight years it's now
being listed for 15 million dollars part
of the reason it's so hard to sell these
cribs
is because you try to pimp out your crib
what does that mean
crazy customizations like we talked
about basketball courts
and man caves and swimming pools and
closets galore and all these
certain things that the average person
might not need so they come in and say
i'm not paying 29 million dollars for
that crib buddy
i'll pay 15 maybe so understand that
these cribs
may not be an asset they may be a
liability an asset
typically generates cash flow versus
cost you cash flow even michael jordan
the goat the greatest player of all time
is having a hard time selling his
mansion so understand that cribs
might leave you ending up with a michael
jordan crying face
and number 10 a spend that
mentality you ever heard that song that
goes spend that [ __ ]
spend that [ __ ] spend a check and get it
right back you ever heard that song
well let me tell you something when you
spend that check you might not get it
right back
you might not have another contract you
might not have
another deal that spend that [ __ ]
mentality
might catch up to you a couple different
case examples so probably the poster
child
for balling out and not saving that
money is alan iverson
aka the answer allen iverson made 120
million dollars over his career
not including endorsements which
actually added up to about 200 million
this guy was notorious for rolling up
his strip clubs
and making it rain and making it rain
metal making it rain over that thing
and allegedly would drop 30 40
50 000 in one night at a strip club
that's a lot of dough okay case example
number two
pop in bottles in the club you got this
guy called robert
swift this guy was in and out of the
league why because he was popping
bottles
and doing drugs he did not save that
money end up being broke seven foot dude
now living on a couch somewhere you can
check that out and case example number
three none other than sir
charles charles barkley apparently lost
over
10 million dollars gambling in vegas
lucky for him he's on
nba on tnt right now making that money
so understand this a spend that [ __ ]
mentality
will lead to a broke lifestyle
now that we're nearing the end of this
segment let's go back to the beginning
did you guess
who number one was on this list well let
me give you the answer now it's none
other than
mr steph curry with the shot boy did you
guess that he's the only player
in the nba making 40 million dollars
this year
so now it's time for what i call the key
takeaways and lessons
from this entire nba ball and on a
budget segment
the most important thing you should
understand is learn this
while you're young a lot of nba players
they come into the league when they're
20 21 they're flooded with millions next
thing you know they're 30 years old and
they're broke
not a good look so for you you might be
you might be 25 you might be 30 you
might not be making a lot of money right
now
but understand your prime income years
are in your 40s
and in your 50s so learn these lessons
now so you don't end up being on
this list and you can hopefully end up
on this list in your career
so understand time is on your side not
on these nba players side
so with that being said you need to have
a long term
game plan for your money when it comes
to a long-term game plan
have a career understand saving
understand investing
understand compound interest long term
game plan here's another point you might
be saying besides these guys are making
10 20 30 million dollars a year how can
i possibly understand that
understand that it's not about the zeros
it's about
the percentage it's about the percentage
you might be making 50 000 but you still
need to be saving
10 percent of your income understand
that these guys need to save a
higher percentage because this money
needs to last them the rest of their
life
so for you it's not about the zero at
the end it's about the percentage
so as they say it's not what you make
it's what you keep and last but not
least i believe in something called the
kiss
principle now what's the kiss principle
it stands for keep it
simple stupid if you don't know about
money and you're just
learning about money i've actually
developed a system on how you can win
the money game it's right here it's
called the six principles of wealth i
break down on how you can win
the money game so thank you and if you
have not subscribed
to valuetainment economics please do so
right here and as always
save that money all we talk is